OK,大家好,我是Yoni,非常开心今天又以直播的形式跟大家见面了哈,那欢迎今天来参加咱们这场分享会的所有小伙伴们,那我们上一次呢,听一鸣老师给咱们做完关于自编码器重构特征工程的分享之后呢,下来之后呢,有蛮多小伙伴都跟我说收获很大,那今天非常感谢一鸣老师又抽出时间来跟大家伙聊,那我们今天聊的是关于评语分析在金融量化研究当中的应用,那相信我肯定又是干活满满。
那接下来大家在听的过程当中呢
可以记录下大家疑惑的点
等一鸣老师分享完之后呢
有问题咱们可以直接上麦提问
好吧那下面我也不多废话
我直接就把时间交给一鸣老师了
一鸣老师
好那咱们现在开始哈
然后今天和大家分享的
主要是这个频率分析
然后在咱们整个的这个
金融量化的研究中的一些应用哈
以及它如何来落地
因为坦率讲因为频率分析
其实大家可能接触的比较少
像一般比如说像我们做这个
信号处理啊
然后还有一些
比如说做无线电啊等等
可能会接触一些和频域相关的内容
那其实它是相当于是
给了我们另外的一个视角
就是说让我们从不同维度来看待
这个金融的这个市场
OK
那其实今天主要的内容还是蛮多的哈
然后其实就是
希望大家能够搞懂
评语分析的
就是整体的这个核心价值
以及它的应用的方向
特别是在这个量化交易
或者叫量化的这个研究的这个领域
对
然后就是可以让我们知道
评语分析能帮我们解决哪类的问题
那第二个部分呢
其实就是我们从这个基础的这个
复利业小波
然后到进阶的这个像HTT啊
VMD啊
补分析来介绍这些
频率分析的经典的这个算法
对
然后呢
另外呢
就是我们会
直接会面对
这个频率分析里的一个坑
那也就是说
后面会讲到的这个边界效应
那其实这个
我们也有比较好的
这个应对方案
对
那最后呢
就是说我们会用
这个国内的这个
RB的这个商品期货
的这个螺龙钢的这个品种呢
来给大家来演示这个实战的这个案例
也就是说分享一下
这个评语分析如何的这个落地
对
OK
然后我们先来讲一下
这个评语分析的
在这个金融量化领域的
这个核心的意义
也就是说它的价值在哪里
就我个人理解
它其实就是给了我们一个
不同的一个视角
因为大家平时习惯性的看到的
基本上都是实域的这个数据
也也就说大家习惯成为
比如说叫时序类的数据
或者或者叫行情类的数据
那其实嗯
频率分析的核心的意义呢
其实就是给我们提供了一个
不同的一个角度
对然后不同的一个视角
对所以他提供的完全是
比如说我们嗯
简单来讲的话
其实就是一个频率能量时间的
这么一个三维的一个视角
对然后呢
让我们从其他的这个维度呢
来更好的来解构这个市场
那当然说也要进行相应的这个周期
以及标的这个匹配哈
那如果我们匹配有问题的话
其实就会造成一个比较严重的
我们叫周期过女和的一个问题
对这个周期过女和和传统的这种
比如说我们用因子啊
用这个呃
就是机器学习做的那个过女和
还是不同的意义哈
对和那个是
那个过礼盒的方式是不同的
对那另外呢
其实就是
那如果是从
那既然他给了我们不同的一个视角的话
那其实可以我们从行业的角度
进行一些我们逻辑的验证
再加上我们在时序上的这个交易的落地
那其实是能够实现收益最大化的
那这个也是他的这个核心的价值和意义的所在
对
另外呢
就是我罗列了四个主要的
这个在金融场景下的
四个应用的方向
那其实最常用的就是
大家看到的这个第一个
就是这个特征工程
对那无论是
比如说我们常用的一些
像是因子
或者是一些差分类的特征
还有像之前我们基普克
以及就是公开的这个主题分享
讲过的这个
比如说商的特征
那无论是信息商
还是样本商
它其实都是一种
不确定性的表达嘛
对那它其实基本上还是基于时序的
对就是在时域的
这个域的域内来进行的
这个特征的这个生成
那无论你是数学逻辑
还是统计逻辑
还是一些特别的计算方法
其实都讨不出这个域哈
因为你基本上的这个视角
还是在时域
但是如果将这个频率分析
放到我们整体的这个特征工程
里面来的话
也就是说作为我们特征工程的一个环节的话
其实它就相当于是把我们实域的一些
所谓线性的数据
其实就是可以转换为频域的这种非线性的结构
对
其实它更能比这个传统的像一些指标类
还有一些因子类的
做一些表层的这种规律的表达
其实它是更有优势的
因为传统的像一些指标
因子其实它有它的这种局限性
对
那这是第一个应用的这个方向
也是我们最常用的
第二个其实就是
做整体的这个宏观分析
对
那像一般比如说
大的这个券商啊
还有一些大的机构
他们做宏观分析的时候
基本上大家都会常会用
这种频率的分析来进行这个
市场的这个结构啊
对那基本上它其实和忽略到
忽略掉了很多的这种短期的波动
可能更重视一些宏观呢
以及和产业相关的一些联系
以及更隐
相当于是更隐性的一些周期驱动的逻辑
其实这个是在宏观分析上
能够得到的这个结果
对
第三个呢
常用的这个应用的方向
基本上就是我们在做这个市场状态
也就是说
像我们常提的
比如说市场regime的分析
那比如说市场regime
现在是一种什么样的状态
对那比如说简单来表达的话
它是比如说它是震荡的状态啊
还是是上涨还是下跌
还是趋势还是哪种状态
对那其实是可以从我们
那当然说传统的也有一些比较好的一种方式
像我们之前课上提的一些方式
其实也都是很好的能够表达
但是呢频率分析
其实它是从另外的一个角度
从这个比如说从频率啊
从能量的分布上的来
来从这个视角上来看待
这个市场的这个regime
那当然说
如果你把这些regime
当成我们特征来讲的话
也就是说把行情的结构
把行情的这些解析出来的信息
那给到特征工程的话
那其实也是一种不错的表达
那最后呢
其实就是我们在这个风险
风险建模上的一些用用
因为频率分析
还是对这个频率的结构
还是蛮敏感
对
所以它会比一些
传统的一些指标类的信息
会更加的靠前能够表达出来
那比如说我们
这个有一些市场的异动
对
那可能指标的话
或者是我们用这个
比如说用样本商
用信息商
或者是用
甚至是用这个
我们用HMM
比如说用这个
马可夫来
他的引状态来表达
这个市场现在的这种regime以及风险
对那其实那这个频率分析
其实是它是一种另外的一种结构的表达
那正常情况下
我们会多个角度同时来判断这个市场
比如说我们频率分析同时也在做
那其他的方式也在做
那其实它就给了我们一个更多的一个视角
对比如说能够让我们在
比如说风控啊
以及风险建模上面
会有更好的一些处理的方式
其实这个就是整个评论分析的核心的价值
以及基本上在金融量化研究的场景下的应用的方向
其实它应用的最多的
因为刚才已经提到了
应用的最多的其实还是
无论是行情的结构还是我们风控等等
其实它最容易表达的
其实就是我们把它的计算的结果
放到我们的这个特征工程中
那比如说我们前面有这个library
有标签
那我们有特征工程
然后呢我们用这个特征工程
来学习我们的那个y
也就是说学习我们的那个标签library
对那我们后面可以给到
比如说非线性的这些模型
那无论你是用传统的这种书啊
还是比如说你是中间会加一些
像我之前做过分享的
也就是说我们课上也会详细讲的
就是这个字编码技法
那无论你是把这些特征
给到这个自变打气之后
再给到非线性的模型去进行训练
还是说是你直接
就是用很
就是用很简单的方式来表达
这种特征工程
那其实都没关系
因为它最重要的应用
就是说是
那我们如何能从这个
频率分析的角度
来找到这个市场的这种周期的规律
对
以及捕捉到这种
我们金融数据
非评论数据的一个
实变的一个特征
那其实这个是最有意义
对
OK
那大家可以看到
这是我是用国内的
这个RB的这个数据
就罗文刚的120分钟的时间轴
这里边是没有用重采样的
这个重采样的
其他的那个自定义表
我们还是用的这个时间轴的
做的这个离散小波的一个变换
那大家可以看到
因为是我们基础是120分钟
对
那所以大家可以看到下面
我们是分了几层哈
那小波机我们用的是db4哈
对那也就是说是
如果是多个频率叠加的话
其实就是上面的这个结果哈
那也就是说它原始的这个
close的这个状态
那其实是这个结果
那下面呢我们是这种
123456哈
然后拆解成了六个不同的这个层级
那从不同的这个层级呢
通过我们的离散的小波变换
然后我们来看到它不同的视角
其实这个只是一个
举了一个很简单的一个例子
不同的视角
其实它表达的意义是不同的
假设说我们
把不同的视角的这个结果
作为特征的话
其实我们是会觉得
在后面用一些非线性的模型
进行训练的话
会得到还蛮不错的这个效果
就单说
频域是可以和这个实域的特征
进行互补的
所以说我们也可以在一些正常
比如说数学统计之类的特征的工程之外
会加一些
比如说像小波
还有后面我们会讲的VMD
然后HTT的这种频率分析的
把它的运算结果
也会加到我们的特征里面
然后来提高我们的模型的训练的效果
OK
那下面的其实就是比较关键的几点
就是这个刚才因为也讲了一些
也就是说我们频率分析和其他特征
主要的差别其实在哪里
对其实大家可以看到
像我们常用的
比如说差分
差分的这个特征
那无论是这个整数界的差分
还是这个分数界的差分
这个都没关系
因为差分只是一种数学的一种表达
对
那这个还有这个像我们一些因子
因为因子可以直接作为我们的特征进行使用
因为因子只是你比特征多了一些检验的这个结果
对
但是这个检验呢
只是对单因子进行检验
并且其实因子本身不重要
因为检验方式是最值钱的
对
所以呢
也就是说你对单一因子进行检验的时候
其实你并不清楚
那这个因子与其他因子之间
会不会产生一些线性
或者是非线性的关系
来更好地表达这个事情
对那只是对于单因子的这些检验
对那所以评语分析
它会对比如说像我们传统的这个
差分也好
是因子也好
然后能够提供一些
更侧重于这个数据内在波动
以及频率方面的这些个特征
对那这个是差分和这个因子
是没有办法表达
下面其实还提到了
与传统的技术指标特征的差别
像一般有的小伙伴
也是习惯性的用
比如说传统的金融类的表达的方式
因为我个人是比较喜欢用
数学表达方式来进行特征工程的话
当然说也有的小伙伴会习惯性的
因为是金融领域
他所以说会习惯性的
用金融的方式来表达
比如说像我们常见的一些
指标比如说那个均线啊
RSI啊
CCI啊
甚至是比如说WR啊
什么MACD等等哈
那其实这个都是基于这些
比如说我们价格本身啊
以及或者是成交量啊
成交额等等的
然后这些简单的统计
或者是数学工具计算出来
对那其实它有它的一些局限性哈
因为它就是指标
其实表达的无外乎就是两类哈
那一类的就是
它是不是有这个短期趋势
或者是长期趋势
那另一类呢
可能就是完全是基于超买超卖的
这一类超买超卖的
可能表达的是市场的这种反转
那是不是能够反转
对那趋势呢
可能表达的是能不能这个再继续
对但是呢
它其实是缺少了
这个频率分析的一个视角
那如果我们用频率分析来看的话
其实也就是说
能够把这个
比如说短期的趋势
以及长期的这种趋势
它的复杂的波动模式
然后按照不同的这个模态
来进行分割
以及我们可以针对每一个模态
进行深入的这种分析
所以它和这种传统的
像数学类的
比如说差分
对
然后无论是整数节
还是分数节
还有比如说像
大家常用到的因子的区别
以及技术指标的差别
然后所以它其实
我强调一下
其实频域分析并不是说是
引导大家用这种方式
来替代现有的特征工程的方式
它不是替代
它更重要的其实是一个互补
是一个另外的一个多维的一个视角
所以也就是说我们在特征工程里面
其实我们可以把这些信息
在这些信息的基础上
再叠加上这个频率分析的这个结果
其实是能让我们更好的
从不同的视角来表达这个市场
它是一个互补的
并不是替代的这个关系
OK
那提到这个基因分析
因为刚才已经讲了一些
它的这种优势了
那具体抽象化
抽象化讲的话
其实就是三点
那第一呢
就是说
它能够这个
捕捉到我们市场的这个
复杂波动的这个模态
或者叫模式
那第二个呢
其实就是对噪音的这种包容度
那也就是说
它的鲁望性更强
那第三呢
也就是说是我们可以
进行多模态
也就是说多分辨的
多分辨率的这种分析能力
那这个其实是传统的这个
像是比如说我们差分
或者是技术指标因子
它是很难来表达的
那所以呢
我们通过这个评语分析
其实能得到
基本上这三类
在传统的数学表达
或者是金融表达上
没有办法能够计算出来的
这个结果
然后我简单讲一下
这个复杂波动模式
其实就是相当于是
因为比如说我们市场
它其实不是简单的一个
单一周期的一个正旋波
因为为什么要提正旋波
因为频率分析
它是来自于
就是做信号
也就是信号分析的这个领域
对那只是我们
只是现在
现在只是把这个频率分析
应用到了这个
我们的这个金融的这种场景下
对那所以
那比如说那金融行情的数据
是不是单一周期的这个正旋波
那其实很显然它不是
那它其实是这种短期的噪音
比如说再加上中期的这种震荡
以及再叠加上这种长期的这种趋势
所以它是把各种信号叠加在一起
那假设说你有一种能力
你可以把这个短期的噪音
以及中期的震荡
以及长期的趋势能够分离开
那是不是就是说
我们可以通过这种方式来更好的
来看待这个市场
也就是说我们视角会不同
那我们可以把这个很多噪音
很多没有办法分辨的信号
金融的这些航行的信号
那我们给它拆解开
那其实我们就可以更清楚的
看待这个市场
对那所以说
这是频率分析的一个优势
对那当然说这个也体现在
这个它的多层的这种
分辨率分析的这种能力
对OK
那咱们频率分析的其实基础
可能大家对这个会比较熟悉
比如说像FFT
比如说像快速负力叶变化
以及小波什么的
然后这个可能大家会比较熟悉
因为坦率讲
因为负力叶和小波
其实是频率分析的
就是我们称作counterstone
就是counterstone
就是整个频率分析的基石
其实就是基于负力叶和小波的
但是负力叶和小波
它是从两个完全不同的视角来看待
这个行情或者叫信号
那复利液其实是我这里边也有写到
那其实复利液呢
是把我们整个平稳的信号的
这个频率整个放大
那它其实就是可以让我们
可以把这个任意周期的信号进行分解
对那就是那其实最好的
就是最简单的办法
就是做这个FFT
就快速复利变换
那假设我们刚才提到的
你的短期的噪音
中期的震荡以及长速的趋势
那这么看起来的话
那我们是不是就可以用
复利变换的方式
把市场行情分为三个模态
那比如说短期的中期的长期的
那其实这个理论上是没有问题的
对那这个是复利变的一个优势
那小波呢
其实是和复利变会有一个互补的
互补的一种表达方式
它其实是把这个C平稳的这种
我们叫防情布局啊
或者叫信号的这个时域上的
这个微观的一些信息能够放大哈
那也就是说我们可以做一些
通过小波的这种变换
那无论是离散小波还是连续小波
那比如说我们会正常情况下
比如说我们对这个实时的这种金融的这个数据
我们可能会提取到时序类的特征
同时比如说我们是不是也可以通过一些频率分析
来实时的来提取频率的特征
比如说像常用的像滑动窗口的负力变换
就是SWFT
其实它是可以把我们的时域分割成固定长度的滑动窗口
然后按照不同的滑动窗口进行FFT的变换
来计算相应的频谱的特征
那其实这个就是它的一个应用
那比如说像还有呢
比如说我们现在常用的这个CWT
也就是说连续小波的这个变换
对
那我们是不是可以
就是做不同的这种
多分辨率的这种分析
然后呢
我们的目的呢
可能比较简单
其实就是尽可能的
把这个市场的噪音
和有效的行情的信号
其实分隔开
对
其实这个是我们的这个
初心和目的
那无论你是
比如说是复利业也好
还是小波也好
那你是用评论信号的频率放大
还是非评论信号的这种实域的
这种微观的
比如说是微移啊
或者是重新构造一组尺度啊
等等其实都没有关系
它其实目的就是说是
能够让我们把这个市场的
噪音和有效的这个房型
能够分离开
那这个是我们做的这个目的
对
那这个是负链和小波
那在这个counters
也就是说在这个两个
傅立和小郭的这个基础之上
其实更进阶的
有很多的这种表达方式
那比如说像这个
希尔伯特黄变换HTT
还有像是比如说像
这个是我常用的
就变分的这个模态的分解
VMD
对以及这种普分系
也就是说这个是比较经典的
像是一些
比如说像我们做一些
最大商的
最大商的普分系来
这个预测这个这个期权的这个引拨哈
对那其实比这个
嗯传统的那个gash模型也要准很多啊
当然说如果是gash模型的话
我们改成分数据的话
那其实它的效果也是还可以的
对不是我只是举一个简单的例子哈
那比如说咱们先讲这个西洋国的黄变化
htt哈
那其实它是可以把我们因为嗯
就是因为金融市场的数据
它其实是第一呢是非平稳
第二呢是非线性
对我们可以这么理解
也就是说非线性和非平稳的这些数据
那我们如何来进行
我们的这个噪音
以及不同尺度的这个分辨率的
这种或者叫模态的分解
对那其实最终我们达到的目的
还是说是我们尽可能的剥离掉噪音
要得到一个市场的一个重要的一个信息
那它现在的重要的信息是
是比如说是上涨还是下跌
还是就是为此中间的这个
价格一直在震荡等等
其实我们都可以从
评语分析可以把它拆解出来
那比如说像HTT
其实它简单来讲的话
其实就相当于是
一种自适应的
拆积木的这个方式
那其实对于HTT来讲
我们其实不用太预设一些参数
它可以自动的把
复杂的这个数据
比如说拆成我们想要的这个IF
IMF
也就是说是各种的这种模态
那比如说我们只可以
比如说我们可以指定一个模态
就可以了
比如说是五个模态
或者是六个模态
那当然说我们后面会给大家看到
这种分析的这个结果
那这个是HTT的一个优势
因为它不用任何的这种调餐
也就是说相当于是
相当于是我们进行了一个
如果类比机器学习的话
就有点像是无监督的这种学习
就是说你不用给它太多的这种标签
甚至是你不用给它标签
你不用对它有更多的约束
对
因为它不太需要复杂的这种
预设参数的这个过程
对
但是它的局限性
其实也是蛮明显的
其实它的局限就是很容易
就进行了这种模态的这种混叠
那也就是说我们比较相邻的
相近的
比如说两个周期
那可能会被拆到一个IMF里面
也就是说拆到一个模态里面
然后会导致我们分析的这个不太准确
对
那当然说我们也可以用HTT
来混合我们的这个变分模态
比如说VMD来混合来使用
对
那这个VMD呢
其实是比这个HTT会更精准的来拆分这种模块
对因为它其实是会会有一些数学上的优化以及约束
那当然说我们也可以进行一些调整
对也就是说进行有约束性的这种拆分
对那它的优势呢
其实就是抗干扰能力
或者叫抗噪音能力是比较强
分解也比较精准
那基本上
做特征工程的时候
那其实我们还是优先选择
这个变分模态来
变分模态分解
也就是说VMD
如果做特征的话
就是可以优先来使用它
那如果做这个
比如说宏观的3C等等
其实我们可以
HTT混合这个VMD来做
来进行这个宏观的这个
周期的这个拆解
那如果是做特征的话
其实VMD还是首选
对
那另外的最后呢
就是一个
嗯
谱分析嘛
那谱分析就是
其实简单来讲的话
就是我们用计算
相应的这个信号的
这个功率谱的密度啊
简称叫PSD啊
对
也就是说我们计算
这个
嗯
其实简单来讲的话
其实它其实就是
计算每一个频率的
这种能量的高低
对
其实我们主观理解
也很好理解啊
那比如说
它是
这种高频上面
它一直是能量比较高的话
那其实我们也证明
它其实市场的regime
其实是在这个状态下
那如果它的计算的
这个频率的能量比较低的话
那其实就证明
这个可能是噪音
所以说它是基于这种
也就是说是周期图法
以及自相关函数
来计算这个PSD
来拆解这个
来拆解这个能量
通过能量高低来拆解
这个不同的这个模态
所以大家可以看到
那我们像频率分析的
比如的
其实就是刚才提到的
这个复利液以及小波
那进阶的这个频率分析
其实就基本上会有三种方式
HTT VMD 还有普分析
我记得好像
Uni你之前也做过
就是好像我看到过
你做过这个
希尔伯特黄变化的这个视频
对
我做过几期视频
然后大家也可以去我那个
主页上搜来看一看
对
就是每个我是单独拧出来
做个做了几分钟的视频
因为我记得是
我是有刷到过的
然后这里边呢
那当然说刚才已经讲到了
那比如说我们的基石是这个
这个快速
比如说斯利安和小波
那这个进阶的呢
那当然说也有这个
希尔伯特黄变化
VMD
以及这种普分析
那常用的其实就是我们最大
最大商股分析
比如说我们预测期权的
引波等等
那其实在频域分析上面
其实会有一个
核心的一个坑
对
那大家可以看到
那我们的中心是什么呢
我们中心是
我们如何用频域分析
来拆解掉市场的噪音
以及真实的信号
那这是我们用频率分析的初心
那它的坑是什么呢
那频率分析的优势很明显
那缺点也很明显
其实就是这个边界效应问题
什么叫边界效应
那比如说我们
从全局最优的方式来看的话
那其实它是没有问题的
那我们可以进行历史上的这种
的这个频率的分析
那么可以拆解成几个模态
来进行这个信号啊
以及这个真正有效信号的这种分析
那其实这是全局最有
简单来讲的话
那我们就是
那在我们比如说
实际的交易的过程中呢
其实我们更希望
它能够把当下行情的这个市场的regime
或者叫当下市场的这个特征
能够很好的表达出来
那其实它和一些像
比如说我们用这个
马可夫啊等等
其实它有点类似哈
就是也会有一个边界的一个问题
那也就是说
我求全局最优的时候是可以的
但是我求这个当下的时候
可能会有一点点问题
那假设我求当下
我能够实现online的计算
也就是说我实时可以在线计算的话
那其实它就可以作为我们的交易模型
对我不知道大家能不能理解
对那假设它能够
实时的推理出
或者叫做计算出我们市场的regime的话
那其实它就可以作为我们的交易的模型
对
但是显然它是很难
就是来表达当下的这个市场的regime
对
那所以呢
我们会采取一些
另类的一些方式
那比如说我们会采用的这个NRBO
也就是说牛顿拉夫逊边界优化
对
其实它优化的主要的这个逻辑
其实就是我们叫滑动窗的卷积
对其实它解决的
其实是这么一个问题
也就是说是
给我们能够动态的补一个
我们叫过渡带
对因为我这块数据是
我当下的是没有的
那它全局最优的话
那它算我当下的时候
我肯定这个当下的这个计算
肯定是不准确的
那假设我们有一种方式
能够通过计算或者是概率的生成
能够把我们边缘的这个信息
能够通过一个动态的方式
来补充上一个过渡信息的话
那其实我们认为
那这个方式是还是能
还是可以比较好解决
这个边界效应问题
那其实就是这个N2BO的这个算法
那其实它是
其实就是用边缘的这个前边
也就是说我们当下边界之前的一些市场的信息
然后呢计算我们相应的这个
比如说我们波动率均值啊等等
然后进行加权来生成一段
近似于这个真实数据的这个虚拟数据
对那也就是说让我们的这个卷积合
其实是有内容可以来算的
因为至少它当下不是空的
对所以这个NRBO其实是完成了
这么一个就是计算的一个效果
其实也是间接解决了
这个边界效应的这个问题
对
那最经典的其实就是
我们可以用这个VMD的方式
然后加上NRBO的方式
那其实这个优势还是非常明显的
这是也是我个人常用的
也是希望推荐给大家的这个方式
VMD加上NRBO的这种方式来
可以把频率分析的这个特征
然后持续的推送到我们的模型里来
也就是说
它对于我们传统的数学
以及金融的持续的特征
会进行一个频域分析上的一个补充
也就是说加上了频域分析的视角
VMD叠加NRBO的这个方式
也是推荐给大家
OK
后面我们会举几个简单的例子
大家可以看到
因为我们待会会用到时间轴
和这个虫采样的自定义轴
对
右边可以大家看到
这个是时间轴
也就是说我们常用的
这个时间维度的数据
是RB的120分钟的时间的数据
大家可以看到
这个分布差分的一阶到
就是一个窗口期到五个窗口期
分布差分
进行分布差分的计算
一个窗口期到五个窗口期
它的这个概率分布的样子
其实是这个样子
因为虚线的部分其实是正台
那其实它已经
就是我们觉得这个是
就是这个是标准的
这个金融市场的这个数据
就基本上都是长这个样子
就是尖峰特别高
那其实就是
证明了它的这个
其实一个传口期到五个传口期
其实我个人习惯叫一阶到五阶
那其实这个不是按阶查核
是分布查核
可能个人的这个习惯不太一样
我习惯叫一阶到五阶
它的这种差分的结果的这个return
其实是基于就是比较小的数量
都会比较多
那这个呢
其实我们之前在课上也证明了
那其实这个尖峰代表的是什么
其实代表的
其实是与它的震荡的频次是正向
对
大家可以看到就是
就是怎么和
就是如何能够理解的相应的
比如说我们虚线是正态分布
那它已经正常情况下
它是这个样子
因为它本来就是这种尖峰
窄尾的这种
的概率分布的样子
那在这种情况下
那其实我们做这种趋势性策略
其实是蛮难的
那因为它的这个峰值很高
因为我们在课上也证明了
它其实是与这个震荡频次是正相关
那也就是说意味着
它的震荡的行情会非常多
那你在这种概率分布的
时序的数据上
如果你做一些趋势类的策略的话
大概率其实是很难赚到钱的
对那比如说我们用最简单的
对用幼儿园的策略
比如说我们用单均线
或者是用这种双均线
我只是举一个简单的例子
对那我们在这个
在这个120分钟的这个时间维度上
其实很难赚到钱
因为它峰值太高了
那其实你在趋势的时候
你挣到钱之后
它其实也会在震荡的时候
把你的钱洗没
对除非是什么呢
除非你能很好的分辨
什么的能分辨
什么是趋势和什么是震荡
那其实这个是很难的
对那基本上全球的这个
交易员都都在找这个方法
对那如何分辨趋势和震荡
对那这个是太大
对那所以呢
那我们改用我们课上讲的
这个同彩样的这个自定义轴
那大家看到了
左边的这个其实是用了
成交额的这个轴
也简称叫Dollars Bar
用成交额的这种
那它的一阶到五阶的概率分布
其实大家可以看到
其实更接近于曲线的正态分布
那也就是说
我们换了一个纯采样的方式
我们没有在时间轴上来做
我们可以在自定义轴上来做
那在做的情况下
那我们既然没有办法区分震荡和趋势
那我们是不是可以换一个角度
我们可以减少震荡
那我们分辨不出来
什么时候震荡
什么时候是趋势
那我们可不可以
就是说用重采样的方式
尽可能的把它的峰值降低
那降低的同时
其实也就证明了
我们是把这个市场上的震荡的
行情的频次降低了
对
那所以那如果
简单对比来讲的话
那即使是双均线策略的话
那你在重采样的这个轴上来做的话
也比在这个时间轴上要赚的要多
那为什么呢
因为它的震荡的这个次数
其实要远远小于这个时间轴
对那其实这个
就是概率分布的接近正派
只是这个我们重采样
自定义轴的优势之一
其实它最核心的一个目的呢
其实就是解决我们时间轴上
就是我们每一个bar
其实是把内部的信息密度
不均匀的一个问题
大家可以试想一下
其实它会影响很多
可能大家会没有考虑过
那比如说我们
在时间轴上做因子挖掘
对
那无论你是什么方法
比如说你是什么符号回归
GP Learn
你还是用这个DAP
遗传算法
你还是用这个Deep Learning来做
甚至是你用分层的IRL
比如说HIRL用墙
用那个层次强化去学习
去逼近它
其实都一样
那因为你给予的是什么
你给予的是这个时间轴
对
那你既然在时间轴上来做的话
因为时间轴它的
每一个班内部的信息密度
它本身就是不均匀
它不均匀的
所以就造成
比如说你的特征
你的因子
它的有效性飘移的一个问题
那其实这个是最常见
那比如说我们因子
有时有效
有时没效
那其实都是因为
你是在时间轴上来做的话
那假设你换一个轴
那为什么我们都会用时间轴呢
其实没有人告诉我们
这个其实交易所的数据
是没有时间概念
它只是流
它只是Data Flow
它只是数据流
那这个时间维度
只是我们自己定义了一个标准
那为什么我们非要用时间做维度呢
我们可以换维度
所以为了解决
这个单一半的内部的这个信息密度均衡的问题
那我们就是尽可能的采用这种
就是重采样的方式
比如说我们进行一些成交量啊
成交额呢
以及价格变化的这种
自定义轴的这种方式的计算
那其实这个也是这个自定义轴的一个优势
因为后面我们要做对比
所以在这边可能我讲的会多一些
那大家可以看到
那刚才讲到了
那我们用的是这个
嗯
左边是用的是这个D1的这个轴
也就是说是这个
Dollar bar的这个轴
是就是成交额
成交额重采样这个轴
那我们让每一个bar内部的信息密度更均匀
那右边呢
是采用的这种传统的
比如说时间轴
我们以120分钟举例子
那我们进行的是什么呢
进行的是这个
CWT
还就是连续小波
加上连连续小小波的计算
加上了一个增强型同步压缩
对
然后这个其实就是
我们会加了一些技术细节
与这种我们叫金融价值的
这种深度的体现
因为我们用CWT就连续小波变换
能够其实能够更好的
也就相当于是我们广撒网
来找到这种频率的这种分层
对
然后呢
但是它能量会比较分散
那同时呢
我们又累加上了SWT
也就是说我们增强的
这种同步压缩
其实能够解决
也就是说把分散的这个能量呢
完全再重新聚集到
对应的这个频率上
那目的呢
其实是让我们的周期更清晰
那两者结合
其实是能够这个找的更全
找的更准
为了起到这个的目的
对
那所以大家可以看到
那这个
就是说是我们的这个
左边的这个
自定义轴
以及右边的这个
时间轴的这个食品的这个图的这个对比呢
那其实能够看到这个自定义轴的这个能量
其实是更集中的
也就是说按照波动率拆分的话
其实它的主导的周期其实是更明确
对那也就是说我们的这种
无论是给的是哪种参数
其实它是实现了更好的这个效果
对那其实也也是变相的
通过这个频率分析来证明了
那我们进行拆解
的有效性
对
那即使是在这种
时间维度上
来进行频率分析的话
那可能也会
有的有效
有的没效
那么我们
采用了
信息密度更均匀的
自定义轴的话
其实实现了
这种效果
其实是更加明显
那也就是说
我们按波动率拆分以后
其实它主导的这个周期
还是比较明显
所以大家都能够看到
对
OK
那这个呢
其实是我们
详细的这个参数设计
以及算法
因为这个其实代码都之前也
给到过我们的这个
就是那个
就是课程的这个小伙伴
这个他们也都有这个代码
对
那其实这个大家可以看到
那我们从这个CWT的参数设计
以及这个SWT的这个算法上面
会有一些特别的这个设置
那其实CWT
其实5F就是三个重点
那一个是这个M波
那M波我们的这个
是取这个1.5到1
还是取多大的这个参数
那以及就是对数尺度的这个材料
那我们是如何
比如说正常情况下
比如说8到128的这种尺度等等
那其实是涉及到一个频率
有效性过滤的一个问题
对那第三个的重点呢
就是说是刚刚才提到
这个频率有效性过滤的这么一个问题
对那其实它的意义呢
其实就是在于通过参数的设计
我们更好地完成我们的初心
那我们初心是什么呢
其实就是把这个噪音和不同尺度上的有效信号
能够给它分离开
能够让我们知道
就是相当于是
那在这个尺度上
那我们应该进行怎样的市场的决策
那假设你是主观交易的话
那可能你得到的是一个
主观的一个分析的这么一个结果
直接会影响到你的决策
那假设你把不同的模态
或者叫不同频率的特征
给到了后面的这个
像我们讲过的这个自媒体
之后再给到非线性模型之后
它会就是模型会自动推理出来一个
就是当前的这个市场的这个
针对市场regime
就是市场状态的一个交易的这么一个信号
对那比如说是做多还是做空
那还是不做等等
那其实是由模型自动来判断的
那同样右边的这个SWT算法
其实它的参数基本上也是在三个方面
一个是顺势频率估计
一个是能量的这个重分配的一个机制
一个是计算效率的一个优化
对这个拿到这个代码的小伙伴
应该就是能够就是通过代码
能够很好的来理解
这个CWT和这个SWT的这个算法
以及参数的这个设置
那我们再来看一下这个
也就是说我个人比较喜欢的
这个VMD与这个NRBO的
也就说是那个牛顿拉夫逊
边界优化做的这个频率分析
对那这个频率分析
也是我会把它直接放到我们的特征工程里面
我们还是做了一个对比
那左边是我们重采样的这个自定义种
那右边呢
这是这个右边还是120分钟的这个时间轴
那大家可以看到
那其实
那我们其实是做了一个模态的分解
以及加上我们进行了一个边界的一个优化
也就是说是这种方案的技术落地的效果
其实是最好的
因为频率分析
不是我们像做模型调谈等等
其实它跟这个关系不是特别大
但是我们也会通过一些
像边界优化的这个效果
来给我们进行相应的优化
大家可以看到
比如说我们看到
左边的自定义轴
和右边的自定义轴的这个边缘的这个部分
那边缘的这个部分
对其实都没有出现
就是突然的这种波动的这种跳变
那其实就证明了这个边界效应
其实已经被抑制了
对而且呢是和这个边
就是边缘的这个模态和这个成分的
这个模态内部完全是一致的
那所以说也是证明了我们用VMD
加上这种这个NRBU
就是牛顿拉夫逊边界优化
其实是起到了很好的
这个意志的这个效果
OK
那这个是我们VMD和NRBO的
这个算法的这个解析
对
那这个VMD其实是两点
那基本上还是这个
第一呢
它是自适应
对
自适应这种多模态的分解
那另外呢
其实就是说
它的金融的价值
就是能够让我们通过
刚才这个图
大家可以看得很明显
也就是说
我们通过不同的拆解
大家可以看到
第二个图
第一个图是市场
原有的close的信号
第二个图其实是
把它拆成一个
非常光滑的
这么一个大的趋势
下面其实是不同的
不同的频次
或者叫不同分辨率的
这种噪音的剥离
对
那也就是说我们剥离出来
来了不同尺度的这种模态
来实现了它的这种光滑度
对那当然说
并不是说是只有第二个图是能用的
那其实下面的这些
其实也可以作为我们的特征
因为这个和我们的交易的频率有关系
那比如说你交易频率是在这个频率上
那其实你可以更多的给它是
这个模态的这个分解的这个结果
那同时呢
也把他的这个完全剥离之后的
这个模态也同时给到特征
那其实是最有效的
那其实并不是说我们每一个模态
就像我们列了一个list
然后每一个模态都要给
那其实这个也要是针对我们
交易的这个频率
对来适当的来选择
这个模
来适当的这种选择的这种模态
那另外呢就是这里边
是我们的这个VMD和这个NR
BO算法的一个简单的一个解释
以及它的核心逻辑
这个之前也都把这个给到过
就代码这个都给到过大家
对
然后其实目的呢
就是说是让我们以
就是因为刚才已经讲到了
那VMD其实比这个HTT
也就是说希尔伯特黄变化
其实是更精准的
对
那比HTT更精准
那与此同时呢
我们又加上了牛顿拉夫逊的边界的优化
其实它已经很好的能够表达
我们叫市场的特征
或者叫市场的GGM的表达
来以及多模态的这种分解
其实我们在针对我们不同交易频率
然后再给到我们相应的
不同的作为我们的特征
然后改造模型
最后实现我们是把市场的
也就是说我们以这种方式来实现
我们的初心
那也就是说
我们把这个噪音剥离之后的
纯视场的这种模态
给到了这个模型去做
作为特征去做训练
那这个效果
其实是要远远要超过
只是给实域信号
那无论你是基于数学的
还是基于这种金融的
那其实如果基于数学的话
其实因为在课程上
大家已经可以看到了
那我们其实只是
很简单的一种数学的
表达的方式
其实我们就可以把模型训练的结果
单一模型卡码能够冲上4
对那假设说我们再给到它
除了实域以外的数学表达
再加上这种频率分析的
这种玻璃
这种噪音之后的
那模态的数据
那其实效果会更好
对OK
那这个就是我今天
和大家分享的这个内容
对然后看看大家有没有问题
可以直接上麦
对 直接提问
OK 非常感谢一鸣老师
刚刚听下来
我跟大家应该都很认真
然后呢
我有一个问题
想问一下
就是像刚刚咱们有提到
那个边界效应的问题
就是怎么样想到
比如说用那个
就是NRBO
然后来那个
就是边界优化来解决
这个问题
OK 其实这个
其实我们之前是
没有采用这种方式
对
然后呢
简单来讲的话
其实就是变相的被市场补打出来的
对
然后最后呢
我们选择的是用这个牛顿拉夫逊边界优化的
这种算法
因为我们当时是对比了不同的这种研拓的方法
的这种残差
我们会看他残差图的时候
然后会有一个细节
那也就是说它金融数据
其实它边缘失真
其实是和它的这种波动强度
是成相关的
对我不知道大家能不能理解
对那也就是说
它波动率比较高的时候
其实边界效应会更明显
对那能不能
其实就是让这个研拓的这种
比如说补值
就是不是那么
只是简单的这种复制
那所以呢我们会
用这个NRBO
也就是说牛顿拉夫逊边界优化的
这个算法来结合
这个当下死尽的这种波动的特征
来进行动态的进行调整
那其实这个是这么来完成的
OK了解了
感谢一鸣老师
我看一下下面
OK一鸣老师你可以看一下评论区
有小伙伴有问题
我想请教NRBO可以用在每天拍盘跳空
每天拍盘
跳高跳空上
直接做评语分析
这种信息会不会
损失
它是这样的
因为大家
一定要站在评语的角度
来看待这个NRBO
因为它和实语上
我们的理解还是不同的
对
比如说像你刚才提到的
能不能用在
这个就是每天
比如说开盘的这种跳高
跳空上
其实它和这个是完全是无关的
对
然后因为它其实更加考虑的是
这个让这个边缘效应更明显
对
那也就是说
我们是用这种方式来优化
进行一个反通败的一个计算
那其实更重要的是
我们得到了它这一段
比较准确的这个识语
评语分析的这个结果
那假设这个结果相应比较准确的话
那也就是说
我们变相的准确的表达市场regime
那我们把这个市场regime的表达呢
作为特征呢
给到我们的模型
对那我们训练出来的这种
最终的这个交易的这个模型
其实它的分化能力还是蛮强的
对那所以呢
它其实是鲁邦性会很好
它和咱们实域上面提到的这种
比如说是跳高啊
跳空什么的
其实关系并不是那么大
并不会造成这部分信息的分支
OK我看还有第二个问题是
为什么ETF具有统计特性
而个股没有
对个股每个价值
也是很多人买卖形成的
这个好像今天没有讲这个
那没关系
对因为我其实是不太推荐做
不太推荐大家做个股的话
因为个股的其实噪音会很大
而ETF其实它是已经指数化
指数化的话
从数学意义上来讲
其实它的统计特性会远远高于个股
其实主要是看待数学的统计意义
因为个股的噪音会大
然后另外它不确定性会更强
基本上个股是不具有统计特性
所以我建议是
大家如果用我们的pipeline
去做模型的话
其实还是建议做这个
比如说是如果是做股票的话
其实还是建议做这个ETF
那当然说是Crypto出来
因为Crypto本身它的这种统计特性就蛮强的
对那所以它做单一标的Crypto是没有问题
但个股的话
这个建议还是不要用我们的这个Petland去做
对统计特性不是那么好
对模型也很难收敛
对它不具有数学意义
所以ETF或者是自己做一个指数
其实ETF国内还是蛮多的
这都可以来做
OK我看下面的
当时我用FFT分解后的频率级A
提出主要频幅后得到频率级B
然后再重新生成新的频率区
然后拟合出来的未来更短一段时间
会出现拟合重复的频率A开始的一段区
通过通过NRBO来
我建议你不要用FFT
对我建议你要不就是用我们刚才提到的这个连续小波
比如说CWT
CWT加SWT
那这是一个比较好的组合
对那另外呢就是这个VMD加上NRBO
对那当然说这个CWT加上SWT以后
也可以加NRBO
我建议是不要用这个FFT来做
因为FFT的这个缺点
还是蛮多的
请问这些滤波方法
是因果的还是非因果的滤波
另外需要选择一个长度的窗口
窗口长度会影响吗
是这样的
首先你可以把它理解成滤波
就是频率分析
你可以把它变相的理解成滤波
但是这个和这个
你提到的这个因果
它是没有关系
其实可以理解为是非因果的
对
那另外的它是主要是
其实是频率能量时间
三个维度叠加的这么一种方式
频率分析
其实是刚才前面也都有讲到
对
所以我调到前面去
调到前面的这核心的价
核心的价值
对
那选择一个长度窗口会
这个是这样的
正常情况下
我们会
如果是做宏观分析的话
当然说我们会做
那个全局最优的方式
那如果是作为
比如说市场regime的解析
以及特征工程的话
我们会有一定的
这种窗口长度
窗口长度
其实会直接影响到效果
那窗口长度
其实和什么有关系
和我们的这个交易频率有关系
对那也就是说
它要和咱们的交易频率能够
就是说是尽可能的能够来表达
我们的这个就是交易频率的那个周期
那比如说你是
比如说是100倍或者是50倍的
你自己的这个交易频率的这个窗口期
比如说是20也好
是50也好
是100也好
它是要以这个自己的那个交易频率为依据
并不是说我随便设定了一个固定的一个窗口期
然后我什么样的交易频率
我都用这个窗口期去计算
那其实也不太好
那当然说如果是用VMD来拆解的话
那其实我们可以通过拆解之后的那个结果
来给到我们的这个来作为我们的特征也可以
但重要的是一定要和自己的这个
一定要和自己的这个交易频率
要能就是适合
对这个是
这个是
就是最大的一个问题
OK我还请问
例子里的训练都是分类模型的
还是二分类模型
是用什么样的模型训练
线性模型还是
例子里
我们这里边并没有做训练
这里边只是我们频率
评语分析的一个拆解
这里面并没有做那个模型的训练
对
你提的这个比如说二分类分类
可能是我们后边
嗯
就是
就是我们给到作为特征之后
要给到模型之后进行的这个模型的
这个训练
对
然后
你说怎么保证不过拟合
嗯
不过拟合的方式其实有很多啊
对
因为我们课上也讲了很多啊
像我们从每一个
Pipeline的
就是每一个生款线的环节
其实都在抑制过敏核
对
那其实从那个降维开始
就已经做了
还有从比如说
你label
就是你标签
是不是也要控制过敏核
对
就是说
就是包括你的这个标签
是不是有泛化能力
然后你的这个特征如何来表达
其实都是在抑制过敏核
对
当然说这个频域分析
可以作为我们实
实域特征的一个补充
然后请问哪些因子适合
哪些因子适合频域分析
因子频域分析放在传统因子处理
比如说标准化之后
标准化之前还是之后
频域分析对因子的处理
我倒是觉得不建议这么来用
我倒是建议可以把它作为因子的补充
对
就是说你对因子进行频率分析
其实是意义是不大
对
因为因子更多的是有效性检验
然后你怎么防止有效性飘移
因为刚才我也已经讲到了
那比如说你是时间轴上做的因子
那你其实大概率会有这个有效性飘移的问题
对
因为本身
你时间轴
它其实就本身不具有统一特性
另外
也就是说你每个巴尔的内部的信息密度是不均匀的
对
所以它的因子的这个飘
有效性飘移的问题会更严重
那更严重的
那你如何来解决呢
你就是说最好是用重采样的
就不用时间轴来做因子
你又迁移到这个重采样的定义轴上
对这些我们课上也都有讲
对另外呢
其实说也就是说
假设你把因子作为特征的话
你即使换了轴以后
那其实它比如说它
它自己有效
它和其他因子有没有非线性的关系
你其实也不清楚
对那其实我们可以
就是用这种非线性的模型进行训练
也就相当于说
我们给它做了一个非线性的一个优化
对因为传统的话
你只是按照不同传统
来给一个线性的组组合
对那这个方式已经是比较
这种方式已经不足以
能够在市场上赚到钱了
现在基本上做因子的团队和机构
也都基本上也都是偏向
像我们课上会讲的
这个机器学习的这个技术路径去转
对
那所以它其实作为因子的一个
一个补充
对并不是说是在因子上
直接做平均分析
期货请问如何处理
移仓换月的问题
这个
还有小伙伴们这个问题
这个移仓换月
是这样的
正常的
其实我们在做这个
量化模型的设计之后
其实我们只是
对于这个鼓励合约
进行这个交易
然后除非是套利
那如果比如说我们是做Uptrash
做套利的话
可能我们会产生这个远期和近期套
或者是不同品种套
或者是远期和近期套
那如果我们做正常的这个交易趋势性策略的话
比如说我们对多个标的不是做套利
就是做这个趋势性策略的话
其实会有这个一仓换月的这个问题
那其实基本上都会是临近了之后
就是临近到换月的时候
其实我们就是把那个交易信号的那个标的会直接
就是会更换成新的那个月份的那个主
就是次主力的合约
对然后呢提前会把这个主力合约的这个仓位会平掉
那当然说这个都是程序自动完成的
这个不这个不太需要去人去去管它
对因为比如说你可以通过这个池塘量
或者是这个成交量
或者是成交量以及池塘量的加权
来算出来
比如说你当下
哪个合约是主力
哪个合约是次主力
对
通过你的计算
那比如说两个合约
接近的时候
那其实你就可以
凭料当下的这个主力合约
来直接来交易次主力
因为它可能过不了几天
就变成主力了
对
OK
S来问
D1和C1 bar的区别是什么
D1 bar和C1 bar的区别
这个也有讲到
因为右边是时间种
右边的是C1
C1是我们课上讲的一个轴
它是基于价格行为
基于价格行为的这么一个资金一重采样的轴
D1是就是简称的dollar
就是基于成交额的
它是不同的重采样的方式
当然说重采样的方式有很多
我们课上也都会详细讲
OK下一个
你适合金融的评论
小波有什么书籍可以推荐吗
小波的书籍
我倒不建议看小波的书籍
其实我们之前课上推荐了一本
他是做那个EMD的
就是有点像我们做那个模态分析的
对
我倒不建议看小波
因为小波其实在评论分析上的优势
并不是那么大
基本上现在都是做这个HTT
还有这个VMD
对
小郭的这个优势不是那么大
然后我把我们之前推荐给大家的
那个书我给你找出来
会推荐的是
叫这个叫非线性
非线性非评论数据
自适应分析方法
对
然后是科学出版社
叫非线性非评论数据
自适应分析方法
对
是会推荐这本书
这本书其实也是做了EMD的那个拆解
OK课程的机器学习是什么
深度学与强化
深度和强化其实不太适合做
因为强化更多的是
森毕的环境下来做
像我们比如说做HRL
做因子或者是像深度呢
可能会我们也会推荐一些
比如说结构化的
Deep Learning的一些个算法
对
当然说我们更多的机器学习
其实是用传统的数目型号
对
其实已经就足够了
比如说大家像
我不知道大家都打没打
那个Cargo的那个比赛
基本上上那个XGB
LGB Card Boost
还有比如说像大家没听过的
这个NG Boost什么的
其实都已经能够很好的解决
这种金融的这种结构化的数据
对
效果也是蛮不错的
基本上卡满了
我们上四吧
能请教和主题关系不大的问题
因子要怎么进行筛选
依靠ICIR的相关性筛选
效果不太好
因子筛选
因子的其实筛选是
就是或者叫检验
其实它是最核心的
也是每家机构最核心的机密
就因子不重要
就检验方式是比较重要
像一般检验方式
我推荐是正常情况下
大家ICIR对应的是什么
对应是return
你对应的是市场的收益率
是return的那条线
对那其实这个是有问题
因为return本身它的噪音就很大
你和有噪音的去比的话
那其实就是你后面肯定会有
这个有效性飘移的问题
那首先如果是走因子路线的话
第一呢你要改变你的这个轴
你不建议在时间轴上做因子
你迁移到自定义轴上
对那这样的话呢
基本上你的有效性交易的问题
会大大的减少
对这是第一
这是底层逻辑
对
这个也就是说跳出时间维度
这是第一
第二个呢
那也就是说我们对应的不是ICIR
就不是那个return
我们对应的是标签
对
那假设说你可以有效的
对市场进行趋势性的标签的标注
那当然我们课上会详细的讲
还用概率聚类去做
对
那比如说你们就是
你可以有很好的方式
去用标签来表达的话
那其实你已经间接的
减少了很多的这种噪音
对
以及市场的不确定性
那其实如果假设你
直接的检验和筛选的
这个验证的
这个不是锐碳
而直接是标签的话
那其实你的这个
因子的有效性检验
其实已经提高了
很高的一个态界
对
然后我们下面的这个问题
是问这个机器学习
就是上次课上讲的
机器学习训练的方式
是什么线性的
我们不会用线性
像比如说拉索
就是像这个线性的
我们都不太会
因为线性的其实很难表达
复杂的金融的特征工程
它是很难表达
你想比如说我们是打标签的
我们有了Y了以后
我们特征作为X
那我们希望X是学习到Y
那学习到Y的话
那你无论是给特征
还是比如说你是食欲也好
是频率也好
你还是因子也好
那其实我们希望能够
用非线性的模型来
让它学习到我们
比如说特征之间
或者叫因子之间的
这种非线性关系
所以说我们一定是会用非线性的
OK请问一下
CWT中小波的选择有什么侧重
CWT其实就是
我们做的是连连续小波
连续小波也就是说
如果是侧重的话
其实就是
你是多少的分辨率
对也就是说你是多少个
简单来讲
你就说多少个模态
对那其实这个是最重要
因为你多少个模态
拆解之后
其实就是相当于是
你要和你自己的那个分辨率
也就是说你用分辨率来
和自己的这个交易频率
来能够来对齐
那当然说实时数据处理的时候
我们也会结合一些像比较
比如说像RWA
我不知道有没有听过
也就是说结合一些像地归小波算法
叫RWA
地波小波算法来实现什么呢
来实现这种我们叫增量计算
而其实它变相是降低了计算的复杂度
OK
标签可以是数一到一之间的连续数字
方便用计算仓位的比例
标签其实是市场的regime的表达
比如说你是一来表达上涨
比如说是负一来表达下跌
这是这个意思
对它基本上是离散的
对是离散的
并不是说连续
对那它的离散呢
不是表面上的这种一零之间的离散
而其实是我们有意的要把它离散化
对就更好的表达
举个例子
那假设比如说最傻的方式
最傻的方式是你上涨就标1
下跌就标0
那其实这个完全是错的
你标注出来的这个
library的对应的return是一条斜线
完全没有回射
那其实这个完全是错的
对因为它完全不具有统计特性
因为我们需要标注出来的是什么
比如说我们在一个上涨的行情中
那即使有回调的话
那其实它标注的还是上涨的这个标签
那这个其实是具有统计意义
对那也就是说
那我们那模型学习的是
这个上涨的这个趋势嘛
对那即使它有回调的话
那其实它的趋势是没有变
那你的标签也是不可以变化的
那其实这是最关键的
对对所以我们是有意的
会把标签变成离散化的
比如说是1是0是-1等
大家比较有热情
我看这个是交易的时候
如果是按标签二分类模型
会一直有信号
那如果评判信号的强度
是得一直来开仓
实际上二分类的话
其实它是
对它一直是online的
不是多就是空
但是这里边会有一个问题
就是说
因为像我们的pipeline
我会告诉大家
会用多模型的组合
通过不同的标签
因为我们的标签
是可以调这种趋势度的
通过不同趋势度的标签
的训练
不同的这个模型
来进行组合
也就是说很好的解决了
就是说你在震荡的时候会不持仓
对因为它模型进行组合之后
的信号不一样的时候
它就不会去交易
也就是说变相的解决了
这个震荡的时候
对然后你是怎么处理的
然后也就是说最终的效果的是
基本上它震荡的时候
是不会持仓的
那它趋势的时候呢
是是一直持仓的
因为你不同趋势感的这个标签
它其实是在趋势的行情下
它的信号是一致的
那其实是这种方式来解决这个问题
那比如说你说你刚才说的设置域值的方式
其实我们在课程上也有讲
我们课程上会用二级模型来表达
那也就是说一级模型推理出来的这个概率
其实是不能当做
它的概率值是不能当做加减仓的这种概率值来用的
因为它一级模型推理出来的这质性度
它不是准确率
但是二级模型我们再训练出来的
那个可以
那它推理出来的那个概率
其实是直接变相的表达了这种准确率
那所以说我们是会教大家用二级模型
来实现这个加点仓的一个方式
OK请教regime能怎么指导决策
不同regime数据用来模型
然后根据当前的状态调整模型
是这样的
regime的表达
其实是我们是把市场regime会当作特征
并不是说市场regime
直接影响到我们的决策
而是我们把regime市场的特征的表达
比如说因子的表达
市场regime的表达
我们都当作特征
那用这个特征来
卖给我们的这个非线性的模型
那以这个特征来训练出来
我们的这个模型
来学习到我们的labor
那这个是最核心的
并不是说我们直接用市场的regime
来指导我们的当下的这个交易
并不是说这么简单的线性的关系
而是我们把它作为特征
通过模型的训练
然后来推理出来
OK
问一仓换月的
主要是换月能为意的价格调空
如果价格处于调空
使用指数数据
还是直接用原始数据
我们的习惯是用指数数据的
我们的习惯是用指数数据
做模型训练
然后推理的时候
就是实时的计算
就是训练使用指数数据
然后实时推理
是接收的也是指数数据
但是交易的话
下单的话是直接下到主力上
是接下的是主力的合约
对因为指数数据已经很好的
已经加权出
已经是处理一遍了
那当然说
你要看你的这个数据提供商
对比如说像国内的话
有几家数据提供商
他的指数的这个处理的方式
还是蛮好的
就直接就能用
当然说我们也可以自己来计算
我们的这个通过
比如说持仓量的这个
以及这个成交量的这个加权的方式
来自己计算我们的指数数据
其实也可以啊
或者是直接从这个数据提供商来订阅
他的那个数据
因为也国内的数据也不太贵哈
就不像我们在海外用的这个像TT啊
CQG这个都是蛮贵的
对然后国内基本上可能就就就一年
可能就比如说便宜的几千块贵点的
就两三万吧
对就还是很便宜的
对但是就建议不要用免费的
估计哈
因为你那个数据出问题
你骂人都找不到地方
对因为人家毕竟是免费的
对
嗯
请问小波一般用db4
用m目前有固定的效率
哦这个没有
对
然后我前面的这个db4
我是用db4给大家举了一个例子
这个我们是用的是RMG
这个是用的是RMG
然后用的是DBC
对这个没有什么限制
但是我推荐大家还是
就是用我刚才提到的
就是并不是说简单的这种效果
而是用连续效果
比如说用CWT加SWT的这种方式
或者是用后面的VMD加NRBBO
这个是我们平时也是在用的
OK
听起来用标签进行分类
你可以测试用回归来做预测吗
回归也可以做
预测但回归比分类会难
比分类的方式会更难一些
你可以试想一下
你是预测下一个半
或者是明天的上涨下跌
各50%的概率简单
还是你直接想预测
明天的close的价格
对
那如果你想预测
明天close的这个价格的话
那这个是非常难的
对
那假如说你是
这个预测明天的这种
上涨的概率和下跌的概率
这个会相对比较简单
对
那所以比如说
预测收益率的话
我大家建议
还是大家不要挑战
对
当然说你可以预测
波动率
对波动率是相对比较
当然说你回归问题
也可以可以变成分类
分类和回归问题
可以两个就是混着用
或者是相互变更的
对你分类也可以变成多分类
你不仅仅是二分类
那回归问题呢
你通过分箱嘛
通过分箱的话
把不同的范围
比如说把回归问题
就变成了多分类的问题
对其实都很好解决
OK CQG
对我们
我们基本上用TT和CQG
老师我有一个问题
OK
我有个天马行空的想法
就是能否用这个VMD Model 2到3的
这个After Noble作为自定义轴的预指
去生成这个自己的数学逻辑
下面的那个自定义的轴
预指做字
也可以
做个减法
然后取个绝对值这样
可以可以
可以的
没问题
对
但是这里边会有一个问题
你是基于多少的频率的
对
你像我们基本上会习惯性
用一分钟做基础数据
来进行累计计算
进行重采
那你计算VMD的话
你是每分钟推吗
如果每分钟推的话
我觉得可能有点不太限制
那当然说
如果你是做crypto的话
做crypto的话
我们之前也有小伙伴
他的自定义轴
是基于一个小时的话
对
就是它是一个小时
为基础数据来进行计算
这个看个人的这个习惯
对
这个想法是没问题的
路是可以
但是可能会直抛起来
会看看它的这种可行性
对
我明白
就是我现在遇到的一个瓶颈
就是那个找不到自定义轴的
那个怎么讲
那个想法
我把所有试过的数学逻辑
都使了一遍
OK
想法的话
其实我好像听不出来你是谁了
其实就是咱们进节课讲的那个方式
就是我就不在这里边说具体的内容
因为是一道课程
对就是我们在进节课里讲的那个方式
你有事吗
对
有的就是基于那个来去做往外的拓展跟延伸
那没关系
那回来咱们私下讨论
对
好
回来咱俩私下讨论
对
OK
看看大家还有没有问题
最后RB等期货有统计特征
这个我没太理解
正常情况下
我们都是基于统计
基于数学的方式
来对这个标的进行特征的计算
OK
老师好像能听到
能听到
我想问一下你那个就是评语特征
它提取之后
就后面就进一步是要去干了
是分析它那个比如说
就是一段时间是否有趋势信号出来
还是说来挖掘它一个什么
作为一个什么目标
这个看用途
我们本身的用途
基本上会是把它作为这个特征来进行表达
对
就比如说就如果是
但他就是你要用那个
提取他频率特征的话
不也得就是那个设置一个
应该得设置一个时间段
那这个时间段
时间窗口应该怎么去
对我们会有一个时间段
因为刚才已经提到
就是这个窗口期
这窗口期
其实是和我本身交易频率是相关的
因为我们本身是不用时间轴的
我们是用自定义轴
所以他会跟我们的这个
自定义轴的这个计算方式的
那个窗口期以及和我们其他
就是非频域的那个特征的那个
那个窗口期我们尽可能的来对齐
对哦那呃那就是就你那个
swt 和 scwt 这一页上面那个
就是前好像前面也就
呃上面就他有你下面有两个那个屏幕图吗
就这两个图他
有什么啊对对对这个这个
就这个左右好像看上去
啊第二行他左边和右边
好像看上去没有什么太大的区别
这个是怎么看的
怎么解读这样
这个其实我们主要是看
它的这种均匀程度
是时间轴上的吗
没有其实我们就是你看它
就是我们左边的这个图
其实就更均匀了
左边那个是指
一日的那个级别
然后右边是120分钟的级别
是吧
左边不是one day的
左边是我们我们是自定义轴
我们的 dollar 吧
对是重采样的轴
这是基于成交额的
对不是 one day 的轴
就是不是日线级别的
对这是完全
呃对右右边是时间是基于时间维度的
对就正常情况下
99.9% 的人会用的这个维度
对那我们基本上是不会用时间维度
来去做教育
对时间维度对他缺对
那就是这个相当于这个频率
吸取出来之后
那是就单纯拿这个频率和它的PSD
去输入作为那个特征输入进去吗
对这个你可以看到
这个是左边的我们的重采样子
自定义轴
右边是时间轴
对它明显的这个概率分布都是不一样
你看右边的这个
就是你在这个轴上
你告诉我你怎么做趋势
因为这一段的峰值就是震荡
你基本上这段的峰值
你怎么做趋势
对你基本上在这边
也也也也会来回被洗
对除非你能很好的分辨出震荡和趋势
但是这个很难
对你怎么来分辨
如果你能有效分辨的话
那那那那那这个全全世界标的的钱
就全是你的
对我们没有办法分辨震荡和趋势
我们只能用采取这种呃变相
也就是换一个维度来去做
我没有办法分辨
但是我能降低你的正当的频次
我把你的频次降低
你频次降低了
其实就是间接解决了
我们的来回被洗的亏损
其实你从图上
你就能看到我们赚的是哪块的钱
从哪部分来亏掉
其实这个是我想表达
还有前面就是说
福利业变换和小博变换
是不建议用FFP
对快速复利
快速复利
我们其实不太建议使用
对因为它很容易同点
对我们建议是
其实这个是我最建议的
VMD加NRBO
对
对你应该不是我们的学员
你如果是是学员的话
你应该都会有这个代码的
对
那那个就是VMD的那一页
就是它下面这几列
就是提取出来的意义是什么
它就是不同的模态
就通过不同的模态来分解
那这个可能最下面
我们觉得它就是噪音
就觉得是噪音
然后越往上面来看
因为第一个图就是
第一个图其实就是
它最初的原始的
那个close的价格
close的价格的走势
是十几年的
是16年的走势
那下面的这个
其实整个就是把趋势整个给洗出来
那下面就是针对不同的这个频率
把它的那个噪音去掉
因为我刚才也讲了
就是频率分析的初心
其实就是剥离
剥离掉这个噪音
以及这个通过这种频率啊
然后能量以及时间的维度
然后就是就是这个三
就是这个三合一的这个维度
来看待这个市场
和我们这个传统的
实际的方式不太一样
当然说
就是你可以看一下
这个我之前做的主题分享
比如说像是整个生产线的拆解
以及自编码器
里面也有其他的一些关于
这个实域方面的内容
那比如说那个第二行
像第二行这个去掉造音之后
这个就是趋势比较明显的这一页
可以再拿这个数据进一步
去进行那个评域特征的剔取
没错没错
可以可以可以
对
那就相当于下面这几行
就是没有什么意义了是吧
下面的话
其实我们更多的
就是剥离出了这种噪音
对
把这个噪音剥离出来
但是这个噪音
其实是从频域角度来剥离的
就并不是说我们传统的
比如说我们用
比如说用滤波等等
就是并没有用
比如说卡尔曼线性
或者是非线性的卡尔曼扩展等等
我们并没有用那种基于石
就是基于时序的方式
对
就是并不是说它那个方式不好
而是说是我们有
就是有不同的解决方案
对
我们也可以进行这个线性的
卡尔曼的滤波
或者是非线性的卡尔曼的
扩展的滤波都可以
对
但是说滤波的方式有很多
那当然说我们也可以站在
频率分析的角度
从这个频率能量的这个角度
来把它拆解开
对
这是不同的技术路径
就是没有没有哪个好或者哪个不好
而是它是相互互补的
对哦明白明白
那那如果就是把它
比如说把它的数据
频率测试起来之后
那就是它比如每个测试频率
它都对应它的psd吗
那它这个低psd的这个频率
它一定是没有用的吗
就是一定是取那个高psd的频率
作为它的频率
还是说低psd的这个测试频率
也有它的作用呢
也有它的作用
对因为这个看我们的交易的这个标的的这个交易周期
对那你如果交易周期特别密集的话
那其实下面的这个其实对于你来讲是有用的
那比如说这个交易频率
我们就是交易频率相对比较高的情况下
那我们就可以可以用这个模态来做我们的回归的策略
就我们就不会做趋势
对因为你短短周期的话
那肯定是震荡的频次会比较多
那可能我们更多的是做这种
这种回归的策略
对而趋势的话
比如说你是做宏观分析的
那可能看待的更多的是上一个
那当然说这个只是举了一个
拆解了几个
其实还可以拆解的更细致
对
对这是指我自己交易的频率
不是指那个时间轴的那个周期
数据的那个周期
对对对
这个和这个要和自己交易的
那个频率要适应上
这是最关键的
对
明白明白
因为你看
就是因为我第一页
其实就写了这个内容
可能大家没太注意看
就是这个
大家可以看到
核心是用周
就是周期的思维解构市场
但是实操中需要注意什么呢
需要注意标的适配性
适配性也就是说
警惕周期过敏和
对这个是最关键的
对
也就是说你的那个周期
要和它要匹配上
对
那就是如果我是
比如说说我是做日内交易的话
那我的那个对于他
就是我那个提供的这个原始数据
对他的这个时间周期有要求
在特征提取之前
就是我用的
就我用来提取特征的这个原始数据
对他的这个周期有要求
这个也有要求
对因为你原始周期的这个频率
比如说你是30分钟还是60分钟
其实它结果是不太相同的
也就是说它的这个周期
就是尽可能的和自己的
这个交易频率来对齐
就比如说你是习惯性的
比如说你不用自定义走
你非要用时间轴
那你时间轴
你至少你的交易频率
和你的那个频率分析的
那个分析的频率是对齐的
比如说你是30分钟的频率
那你在这个数据
你就可以基于30分钟来拆
相当于后面有平补图的
你那个轴它也不是时间
是吧
是自定义的
就是SCWT的
我们都是两两做的对比
对
就是一个是时间
这个也是两个做的对比
然后这个也是两个做的对比
明白
你看细节是不太一样的
比如说你看最下面的细节的部分
完全是不同的
你看到了吗
你可以对比一下
比如说倒数第二行
你看这个位置和这个位置
完全是不同的
你看包括到最后
对它也是不同的
但是它上位是相同的
为什么这个图的它的横坐标
还是时间的
对啊
横坐标肯定是时间的
对
但那是不是相当于把它
这个是大的时间
因为我的数据是十几年的
是十几年的
对它只是标了年
对但是它具体里边的
那个时间戳是完全不同的
因为轴是不同的
对否则结果就一样了
明白明白
好谢谢老师
没关系
OK
我看看
RBO用拓展减少
RBO用来拓展
是一减少边界效应
突然也是猜测对吧
如果猜的不对
它不是猜测
它是加权通过
比如说波动率
通过均值等等
它是会计算的
并不是说是
会起到相反的作用
因为它是一个
补缺的一个作用
它当然说只是用在
用在频域分析上
很少我们会用在
实域分析上用这个方式
实域分析上的话
其实我们更多
如果来计算的话
我们看未来数据的话
基本上我们会看期权的引拨
对我们那因为那个是未来的
对然后你除了引拨以外
就是说你除了这个期权的引拨以外
其实你所有的数据都是历史的
对
OK最后两个问题
预测下一个bar指向上一个bar的信息
还是多少个
这个不是只用上一个bar的信息
这个是要有窗口期的
对有窗口期的
对比如说你是bar和bar之间的关系
还有bar内部的关系
对
OKPPT的罗文RB期货有统计特征
PPT中的罗文钢的RB等期货有统计特性
对RB是有具有统计特性的
没问题
个股是没有的
对
然后这个
这个
简单来讲吧
因为我知道你想问
我知道你想问什么
其实你就这么来想
就是相当于是
如果能用很少的钱
就能就是能够左右它行情的话
那其实就代表没有统计特性
简单来解释的话
对这是底层逻辑
如果用很少的钱
你改变不了这个市场的行情的话
那其实它大概率会具有统计特性
比如个股的话
比如小盘股
对你可能几个亿
你就能做一点事情
但是你比如说罗文黄金
你几个亿
你在里边你改变不了什么
对
我不知道我解释的清不清楚
假设你能改变的话
其实就证明别人也能改变
其实它噪音会很多
对
其实这是底层逻辑
OK
好
没关系
然后看看大家还有没有别的问题
我今天大家伙比较热情
两个小时
对
然后辛苦一名老师
其实我想再问一下
像咱们频率分析
在市场状态的解析
或是判别上
是不是可以理解为
它其实有点类似于
HMM的隐状态
您觉得呢
OK好问题
对然后是这样的
因为其实市场regime的判断
其实有几种技术路线
像你提到的这个隐状态
比如说是用这个HMM
那无论是这种
比如说银马尔可夫
还是说是最大商马尔可夫
比如说阿密
其实都一样
它其实表达的更多的是一个
概率的一个问题
对
就是这两个其实是类似
但是其实是数学基础是完全不同的
对
那如果是用频率分析来做这个市场率
这面的解析的话
其实它是和HRM可以是进行互补的
对
简单来讲的话
就是HRM是更多的是概率
用概率的方式来表达这个引状态
对
而这个频率呢
其实是以这个模态或者叫分辨率
就不同的尺度来表达这个市场的状态
基本上靠的是结构
对
那这个HRM基本上用的是概率
所以它是类似的方式
就市场的表达的方式是类似的
但是就是说数学基础是不同的
其实可以起到一个互补的作用
对
OK
那如果说像我们把频率分析
应用到特征工程里面
那就需要注意哪些点呢
其实刚才也有讲到了
其实我不见得
就是单独使用频率分析的结果
作为唯一的特征
我还是希望更多的是
以这个实域
就是实域的这个
实际的这个数据的
比如说统计
这个数学的表达
甚至是金融的表达
来就是来做主要的这个特征
对然后呢
用这个频率分析的这个特征
作为它的一个补充
因为毕竟它们的视角是互补的
那互补的情况下呢
你不知道它们特征和特征之间
会产生哪一类的非线性的这个关系
对这个是我们想用模型训练出来
看到的这个结果
那当然说也可以不
就是不见得把特征直接扔给这个
不见得直接扔给非线性的模型去训练
因为我们课程上也讲了
那我们其实建议是
大家是用降维
用降维的方式来重构一下特征
对因为我之前也做过一个自编码器的一个
主题分享的课
然后大家也可以去那个
去去那个是看看那个视频
对那如果你是非线性的话呢
那比如说我们就用比如说像 pc 呀
然后用这个整个做飞行就就是做
嗯做这个嗯
就是斜方差矩阵的这个
嗯方差的这个排排序嘛相当于他
他是做了一个那个
嗯特征的一个重构嘛
那当然说你如果是用
更复杂的这个自编码器
那无论是比如说是基于循环的
比如说你里边嵌了这个RSTM
还是嵌了那个JRU
其实都OK
因为它是基于
基于那个循环神经网络的
你是用了变相
用了这个循环神经网络的
这个隐藏层的输出
来作为你后面的这个输入
对因为就是变相实现了这个
就是用编码器来实现
这个飞线性的降雷
对
然后就是这个几种方式都是可以的
所以需要注意的还是就是
它作为正常的特征的一个补充
但是不能完全的独立的来使用
因为我们最终的目标不是说是为了炫技
并不是说是炫技
然后来实现更复杂的这种频率的
进入频率的这种特征
而是说是我们希望模型通过这个特征的表达
能够更准确的学习到当下的这个市场regime
因为市场regime是什么给的呢
是我们的这个标签给的掉的
也就是说它更好能学习到这个标签
还有小伙伴们
我们还想请教分析出频谱的强度之后
怎么来进行regime分类
直接给强度设置域值来分类
强度的域值
用聚类算法
它是这样的
其实我们Pipeline也有讲
其实是
我们希望是能够从全局角度来看待
整个的这个Pipeline的设计
也就是说我们要
要做一个模型训练的话
我们其实更多的
其实是工程上
一种乘上起下
就是会有一个全局观
这个是最重要的
而并不是说是我们针对问题
来解决问题
那其实这个是陷入了问题当中
如果是我来解
就是解决这个的话
其实我
我是希望能够站在更高维度
来看这个事情
之所以有频率分析这个事
我们是从全局来讲的话
其实是希望它作为
我们传统特征的一个补充
对
然后通过这个补充呢
那我们通过
无论是线性还是非线性的降维
然后再给到我们的非线性的模型
能够找到频域的
频域的特征和实域的特征之间的
非线性的关系
那这个是最核心
并不是说我们
就是头疼一头脚疼一脚
而是直接用它的
的这个市场的
比如说这个强度
然后来设置一些
预值来进行强分类
对那这种表达其实是
就问题解决问题
我们还是希望能够
就是通过
更多的非线性的
这种模型的训练
来最终来让模型自动推理出来
就是让推理出来
这个市场的
是如何交易的
这个信号
比如说它是做多还是做空
还是怎样
这个是我想表达
我看我国内的时间
现在是十点
非常非常感谢
一鸣老师
今天大家小伙伴们都比较热情
对
然后呢
咱们待会儿差不多也就结束了
以免给一鸣老师
三十秒钟
那个喝点水的时间了
今天聊的比较多
对
然后呢
最后一个问题
待会儿一鸣老师回答吧
您可以先稍微休息一下
然后呢
我跟
就我
我提前来做个总结吧
就是非常感谢
今天来听咱们这场分享会的小伙伴们
大家也
就是感受到大家的热情了
然后呢
因为刚刚我们一直
一鸣老师有提到像
关于线下课的问题
然后呢
其实我想说的是因为
可能很多小伙伴
我也跟大家有提过
有关于这个课的事
就是说如果说
大家对于英文老师的线下课
想要系统的对于量化的
就整个pipeline
然后呢
就是想完全上手的话呢
其实更多建议
可以直接来听咱们的线下课
因为呢
就是其实市场里面的知识
是海量的
有非常多的知识点
但其实难的就是
我们如果要把这些
所有的知识点挨个挨个去试错
其实成本非常的高
一方面是时间
一方面是精力
还有一方面就是成本
对所以说就
如果是大家感兴趣的
然后可以来联系到我
对然后我们下次十月份的
那个移民老师的线下课
是在中旬
包括今天咱们这场会议
刚刚有上来
就是问问题的小伙伴
也是之前听过咱们课的小伙伴
所以说移民老师的课呢
因为我们都不是专业卖课的
就专门搞这种东西的
就都不是啊
移民老师的课
我个人来说
我感受到我不夸张的
说真的可以说是
现在目前国内能够听到量化相关最顶级的课程了
而且是没有什么水分
是真的是讲真东西
因为英明老师他不做国内市场
所以说跟大家没什么影响
如果他做国内市场
他不可能去讲这些的
而且本身他们的管理规模也还比较可观
所以说这点大家活到不用担心说
我来听能不能听到真东西
就这点完全大家可以放心
好吧
那最后把时间交给英明老师
英明老师再回来一下
刚刚有小伙伴问的问题
OK
标签聚类是什么意思
弄一节到五节
加全
不是
这是我们课上会讲的一个
做标签的一个方式
对
就是我们如何来
用这种概率聚类的方式
来进行这个标签的标注
对
进行趋势性标签的标注
OK
今天这个
今天聊的比较晚
对
然后反正我想说的就是
就因为英文老师
线下课讲整个生产线
就是每一步都会讲的非常详细
就包括像我们之前有些小伙伴
说哎呀
我刚刚入门
我可能是个萌新
很多都不知道
对
但其实首先
首先的话
后面也有那个
专门课程答疑的那个
的时候
对
如果大家有
有一问的话
可以专门对课程进行那个答疑
就是不是今天啊
因为今天比较晚了
因为我们和国内还是有事
是他的哈
对然后那个这个回来
看什么时候让Uni再做一个那个课程
课程的那个答疑
对OK
就反正这个
就是我想表达的就是
像有的教科班担心说自己是萌新
就一鸣老师的课确实
其实我个人感受下来
它是其实
我更倾向于什么类型的小伙伴来听
就是后面如果说你想往职业量化发展
职业量化方向发展的小伙伴
你们可以选择来听
因为确实真的
赶果非常非常多
我敢说国内已经找不到
目前找不到第二个
能够讲这么真东西出来的了
对
然后呢就是每一步
整个pipe plan每一步都会
给到大家原代码
对
当然代码其实不是最重要的
因为课上会讲到很多的技术路径
就这个就是实际是在马背后的逻辑
这个是很重要的
对
包括之前有很多来听过小伙
听过课的小伙伴们
大家也都拿到了蛮不错的结果
其实每次大家跟我聊这个
我是最开心的
然后呢
差不多今天咱们时间也比较晚了哈
来非常感谢大家
今天晚上这么晚了都还
我们都还共享这此时此刻好吗
非常感谢大家
然后呢包括大家下来
如果说啊
比如说想要这个
今天晚上分享了这个PPT
也可以联系我这边
可以再发给大家
然后大家再看一看
好不好
然后呢
今天也非常感谢英明老师
感谢大家
好不好
那咱们就下次再见咯
那下一次
我还会组织不同的
这样的线上技术分享
包括英明老师的
这个线下的课程答疑
专门关于课程的
大家如果后面想了解的
也都可以跟我联系
好吗
感谢大家
拜拜
谢谢